[Music]
our marriage was very difficult for many
years
a lot of things that we've experienced
that our this is kind of shaped us and
made us who we are
I'm Vanessa Maureen and this is my
husband Eli Maureen and we've been
married ten years today it's our wedding
anniversary and we live in San Antonio
Texas it was so overwhelming when we saw
that we had over $200,000 of debt it was
scary and we thought there's no way how
are we gonna do this I mean we barely
make any money it's been a journey here
she has been some of the things that we
went through while we were going through
our debt free process is I was diagnosed
with a pituitary tumor and in the middle
of this to find that news just was
disheartening you know I have to have
MRIs every year and try to see is it
growing is it not and that kind of was
really hard on us because we didn't know
what my health situation was like and
further down that road we found out that
we were anything to have children and
the only way that we would be allowed to
is through in vitro we had to choose are
we gonna pay off her debt or go into
debt to have a baby and we decided that
we weren't gonna do that we wanted to be
debt-free
the first major hiccup I think that we
had was when Eli lost his job he had had
a job for about nine years I was taken
aback I thought we were so far along in
our journey and now Eli loses his job
what's gonna happen and I just said
that's okay it's fine
the accident that was a huge turning
point for us literally two days after he
lost his job
I was just sitting in the car was
literally sitting having this
conversation he's like I think things
are gonna work out we're gonna be okay I
think there's an opportunity coming so
while I have them on the phone I opened
my car door and as I let my foot off the
brake it just rolled back and it
happened so fast if I tried to outrun it
I couldn't go anywhere and the car was
rolling back on me and plowed me to the
ground my face first and I remember the
tires rolling over my left side of my
back and I remember at that time I'm
gonna die
like I don't think I'm gonna survive
over this and evilly comes running out
barefoot he sees my face and I'll never
forget he said oh my god oh my god oh my
god he couldn't stop screaming it and he
was I mean he was not in control of
himself at that moment and him he picked
me up he put me back in the rental car
even a rental car that ran me over he
put me in there barefoot drove me
straight to him an urgent care place but
I just said babe I just need to pray and
I said I don't know what's gonna happen
but I love you no matter what I love you
and if I'm not here anymore it'll be
okay I just can't believe how she cooked
that and it made this horrible tragic
accident about at anyone else and it was
it was a lot it was a lot to take in
it was a lot to take in
neither of us are working right
Vanessa's a teacher so she too got one
more check and mine immediately stopped
we're at home together healing and then
he got a job I'm at home for maybe more
than a month and then a boy loses his
job again I always tell aloy one of the
turning points for me this was the main
turning point for me I told him I'm so
tired of life happening to us from now
on I'm gonna start happening to life
that's it no more life happening to us
and at that moment everything changed
like my mindset changed that was my
turning point it was I'm tired feeling
sorry for myself I'm gonna be proactive
you know that that was definitely the
turning point for Vanessa I mean I I
felt it the environment change the
atmosphere change and an issue is dead
serious Anna and I said okay well that's
what we're gonna do
I went to three or four schools dropped
off my resume and just prayed for the
best the next day I get a phone call
from the principal that I currently work
for right now
and she said can you come in I want to
interview you and I said yes absolutely
and it was one mile away from where we
live and um I went and I got the job we
have a friend
I have a company here in town this is
like we need some help
what do you think and I said well i'ma
talk to Vanessa and I'll call you back
that's how I started working again you
know we knew that we could survive on
her Jack so everything I make everything
my entire check has been for debt and we
live off the teacher salary even now and
we don't plan to change that we were two
months away from being debt-free we had
been just that snowball was rolling and
rolling and we're praying so thousands
and thousands of dollars a month aside
for that and San Antonio I had one of
the worst hail storms we'd ever had and
our cars are smashed glass everywhere
water built up inside and we just could
not believe it and we thought no all of
this happened while we were like right
here in the apartment we didn't even
know we still have them to this day they
have holes all over them but they work
when when we found out the cars were
damaged we allowed the insurance to take
the cars and then with the money they
gave us we purchased the cars back at
pennies on the dollar
we used the difference the tamper to pay
off our debt and that's how we got to
the end that's how we got to the mm-hmm
yeah
[Music]
when I think back about everything that
we've been through all of the adversity
this program just taught us how to live
the right way and how to be generous and
how to plan for the future and I'm so
thankful that we had the opportunity to
take that class and I would just
encourage anybody just to go and
experience this life transformation that
that FPU offers we are doing so well now
today especially being our ten-year
anniversary you know when we look back
we've gone through so much and I'm so
thankful to have a boy for a partner and
just we held tight and we just said this
is it we said I do years back and we're
gonna keep marching forward just gonna
keep going and there is no reason for us
so to allow these circumstances to drive
a wedge in between us life hit us really
hard but a life is not bigger than God
not the God we serve it's not I just
know that this is just a chapter of our
story I can't wait to start the next
chapter I believe that the next chapter
is gonna be awesome I know that he has
great plans for us this has been an
amazing ride it's so worth it absolutely
[Music]
you